[Music]  everything alright miss what's your name  what is your address oh no how about  your birthday I don't know we're trying  to understand what happened to you I  knew something was wrong with me but I  couldn't explain it to anyone it was  like the people around me were keeping a  secret  like we were in a movie and everyone  knew we were in a movie except for me if  I did something wrong I have no idea  what it is the complaints been elevated  there's going to be an investigation  it was hard for me to come down here  okay there's no one I can it's hard for  me to talk about this I'm sorry Jesus  what you went through here to think this  is all critical military technology  they're in charge here whether we like  it or not then you like it what was that  doing why was that me it's complicated  how did we get here  [Music]  no good can come of that what if we let  the crazy world if you keep picking at  this it's gonna start bleeding  [Music]